hello everyone and welcome to beginner
breakdown this is a show that we did a
while ago and we're bringing back i am
uh alex mollering i'm gonna be your
instructor for this show and i'm happy
to be here
and tonight our theme is surveying the
scene
so when i think about a chess game one
of the first questions i have and if
you're looking at a board if you're a
player or a spectator you want to get a
sense of well who's winning what's going
on in the game
that's where we're going to start
how do we evaluate a position what kinds
of things do we need to look out for
and that's where we're going to start
tonight
so the first question i have is why
do we count material
material if you're not familiar is
what we name all of these different
pieces it's all material and each of
these the pawns
the queen the bishop the knight the rook
everything has a material value
the king doesn't because it's most
important piece if you lose the king you
lose the game um
but there's a question of well let's
start at the very beginning why do we
count material
so in this position
it's black to move and try and come up
with a plan
and there's a lot of things going on
here it might look pretty complicated
there's some interesting pawn formations
we have
uh
against whites
and there's a huge climactic battle here
in the center that's leaving us asking
okay well what on earth should we do
here
um
and so i would say let's just start by
counting it up
so
each side okay we have a bishop so that
cancels out we both have a knight that
cancels out
we both have two rooks obviously we both
have a king so all of the pieces cancel
out now let's just look at everything
else we have some pawns so black has
one two three four five six pawns and
white has one two three four
so that means black is up in material
we're two pawns or two points up
so whenever you're up in material a good
general rule to follow is try and trade
stuff down
and in this case we actually can uh and
we can start this big massive trade here
in the center
i would start with the bishop because
now we're hitting the king and the
bishop and this is check so this is
forcing a response from our opponent
most likely they're going to take with
the bishop
because if they take with the rook we
can get it for a night and we're winning
that exchange so after the bishop takes
again you have an option i would
probably take with the rook as it's the
most forcing and we're making a lot of
threats
and remember we're up in material as the
black side we want to trade pieces and
we're going to talk about why
after we trade again maybe we do
something like this
and all the pieces get traded
if we take a look at the board now
everything has cleared out from the
center this massive trade and now it's
our turn to move i would probably in
this position play the move king to d5
taking opposition and restricting the
space from my opponent's king
and then we can take another look at the
material it's the same as before all of
the pieces have been traded so they're
all gone and we both have a king
but now
my
six pawns are actually a pretty
significant advantage over here too
it's going to be a lot easier for me to
sort through the chaos of what this
position was
and just be able to win an end game with
some pawns
i don't know exactly what my plan would
be but
i'm gonna have much more space and much
more options my pawns will beat my
opponents on this side even if my king
doesn't so i can use my king to just
keep
keep away essentially and force this
king away and it should be a pretty easy
win
that's the very bottom line of why do we
count material
helping us to get a sense of
well what should i do in this position
who's winning who has more material
and then getting some complexity and
simplicity in the game
however it's not quite that simple we
don't know who's winning a chess game
just based on which pieces are on the
board
because there's lots of times when
people make sacrifices
there's lots of times where people win
in positions where they have way less
material so we need to explore a little
bit farther
how do material values change
and so
if we're talking about the opening in
the middle game
there's something important to note
about material value so let's just look
at the sample line
we have a king's pawn game met with e5
again very classic chess here knight f3
and knight c6
bishop comes out so we have an italian
game and bishop c5 this is a very common
idea a lot of
kind of beginner games feature this but
it's also featured at the high level
it's just very solid stuff
and we see castles knight to f6
and now knight to g5 a little bit on the
aggressive side normally it would be
advised for white to continue developing
maybe bring this knight out
maybe defend the pawn here on e4 that's
just been attacked
maybe bring a rook out there's lots of
options
but moving this same piece is a little
questionable and we're gonna see why but
white has an important reason for doing
this that's a bit problematic
after black castles
uh white made an interesting decision
here
and they took this pawn on f7
rook takes bishop takes and king takes
and white is saying
well the material is equal right so why
does it matter
and if we go back
when we think about the material count
if i didn't say before most people are
going to be familiar with this but we
generally think of a pawn as being worth
one point
the knights and the bishops as being
worth three
the queen being worth nine
and then the rooks are worth five a
piece and again we can't evaluate the
king because it's the most important if
you lose it you lose the game
so white's saying okay i have two pieces
here a bishop and a knight both three
points so that's six and my opponent has
this pawn and this rook
five and one that's also six so why
shouldn't i just trade all this stuff
it's even right
so again counting material is a good
first step but this is actually a bit of
a problem because if we look at this
position
even though
white's knight and bishop are
technically worth the same as black's
rick and pawn
black is a lot better in this position
what's the reason
it's piece activity it's we had material
on the board we had a knight
and we had a bishop and now they're gone
and yeah we got rid of a rook and a pawn
but what were these pieces doing
our pieces were much more active
and so we've given up our
best pieces if you actually look at this
position
all of white's remaining pieces not the
pawns the pieces
are stuck here on the back rank and if
we look at black well they have a
beautiful bishop they have a knight that
wants to jump in maybe a knight is going
to come over here and assisted by the
queen
black's pieces are already developed and
ready to go
so this is a really big problem
so we can't just make evaluations based
on the material count but it is a good
place to start we have to think also
about why pieces are worth what they're
worth
so why would we say a pawn is worth one
or a knight is worth three or a bishop
or three or you know etc
and the reason is because of their scope
and their range
so if we go back and just look at all
these pieces the pawn is worth one
because it moves the slowest right at
the beginning it can move two spaces
after that it can only move one and it
only covers two spaces wherever it is in
terms of what it's attacking now if you
get up onto the end it promotes and that
changes the game but until then or until
it gets closer
it's not really doing much so it's worth
one
the knights and the bishops if we think
about these the knights move really
weird so they're hitting a lot of space
but they have to be in certain areas
right if we go back to
our position here
after this trade is all completed
well this night is not nearly as good as
this night and we can figure out why
very easily it's about how much space
they're controlling
this knight can right now move to this
space
this space and this space so it's got
three options
all of them are pretty much in white's
territory white already is controlling
all of these spaces
let's look at blacks knight here for
instance
it's controlling one
two three four
you can already see it's controlling
eight spaces and some of these are in
its own territory
but all of these squares are really
important at this point in the game
same thing with the bishops right this
bishop is actually doing nothing it's
stuck completely behind these pawns
versus black's beautiful bishop is
active and on a very nice line
controlling a lot of spaces
so point uh pieces are valued
differently because of their power and
what they can control
the queen because she can move in every
direction is worth nine she has the most
options as a general rule but there are
some cases where a queen could be
trapped in a corner and not really doing
much so we have to keep these things in
our consideration
something else that changes
how we evaluate a position
is if we go back here and look remember
we just said okay well maybe a knight
and a bishop aren't worth this rook and
pawn because right now it's the opening
it's the middle game getting our pieces
into the game is crucial we need to have
more forces protecting the center
um
and right now the bishop and the knight
are doing that way more than this rook
and pawn
however what if we were to look at an
end game
if we had traded all these pieces off
the board
and we're in a very simple end game you
can have a king and knight in a bishop
this is our six points here and it is
possible to checkmate your opponent i
don't know how to do it grandmasters
have messed it up in professional
tournaments for a lot of money so
if you want to have these two versus
maybe something like i don't know this
you're rooking your pawn it's the same
six points but it's in a very different
context here
it's going to be a lot easier in a
simplified end game maybe to use your
rook and pawn than it would be to use
your knight and bishop
even though they're worth the same
points
so how we evaluate material is going to
change depending on the context that is
important to keep in mind and the
general rule
is how much space are they going to be
able to control how easy is it going to
be for us to use those pieces to our
advantage
something else that can impact
the material value how we should
evaluate that
is
the kind of position we're in in the
chess game so a very general distinction
that we chess players use is open and
closed games
an open game
is the kind of game where the pawns in
the center specifically these four
central pawns that are on the files with
the king and the queen
those are going to be exchanged or at
least have the opportunity to be
exchanged so in this kind of situation
we might see
just a random opening idea
that features quite a lot of exchanges
here in the center and then this
position
again this is just a random sample
nothing to stress about but you can see
that these pawns are all cleared from
the board
in an open game
we're going to play a little different
than if we were in let's say a closed
game if we go back to the beginning and
instead of e5 our opponent just plays e6
this might lead into a french style
position
and one of the very common ways that
players play against this is they play
the movie e5 this is a advanced
variation
and now you can see this is very
different the pawns are interlocked
they're stuck next to each other they
don't have any options to trade and move
out of the way
and if we have a closed type game that's
going to impact how we play and that's
going to impact how we evaluate our
pieces
in an open game
where there's no pawns here in the
center two rows our bishops become
wildly more powerful
if we just look at this position again
the material is equal both sides have
six pawns
both sides have two minor pieces black
has two knights white has two bishops
and both sides have two rooks and a king
so the piece value is uh equal
but white has a significant advantage i
think stockfish evaluates this position
at about plus two plus 2.5 um
and the reason is you look at the scope
that these pieces have so both of these
bishops are beautifully lined up
pointing on these long diagonals each of
them controlling a massive amount of
space
and these knights are good i mean
they're in nice central positions
but
they can't hold a candle to what the
bishops can do in this position
but now let's flip it around and let's
say we're in a more closed type game
this isn't exactly a fully closed game
obviously white's missing upon here and
it's not locked up but even something as
simple as this we can see okay well
these pawns are locked this pawn is
locked
um
leaving this bishop trapped it can't
project its influence at the king
because it's trapped behind its own pawn
and versus this knight well there's not
pawns here to challenge so we have an
outpost at night and if you look at the
level of control this knight is exerting
on black's king side
and queen side just the whole board it's
just a monster night here in the center
so the types of pawn structures we have
and the position we're in whether it's
an open and closed game whether we're in
the opening or maybe the end game these
are all going to impact
how we evaluate the position and how we
evaluate our own pieces
so now we're going to move into an
actual game
and i'm not going to show you well i'll
show you the whole game but we're not
going to hyper analyze the beginning
because i'm using this to express a
certain point
this game happened in 1868 and it
actually featured a player who you might
have heard of named max lang
he had the white pieces and some people
called him the mad max of chess at least
now they call him that because he played
some crazy aggressive ideas
and this game actually features some of
that
but we're going to take a look and see
if we can find some improvements that he
could have made and his opponent could
have made
so if we start here we're actually going
to see a king's gambit i'm sorry not a
king's game but that would be f4
but this kind of
delayed maybe king's gambit
where after some exchanges uh black
plays aggressively and white's actually
going to sacrifice their knight to get
rapid development and peace activity
this is a theoretical opening
that it's still okay for black or sorry
for white to do um both sides have to be
very careful though
and so again we see some very flashy
aggressive sacrifices white's given up
at night
and now is giving up a bishop all to
activate their pieces and to expose the
opponent's king
and again we're not going to analyze
these moves too much
but max lang does get into a really
strong position
and he actually gives his opponent the
chance to come back
so in this position uh white plays king
g2 with the point of
activating the rook and all of white's
pieces are really aimed
at black's king
versus black's pieces are having a lot
of trouble getting into the game
so white's pieces are better here even
though they've given up a lot of
material
and in this position max lang could have
played a really strong winning idea
um i'll give the chat a minute to take a
look i won't spend too much time but if
you have any ideas of what
black could do here feel free to say
something
if not that's okay
but black to move or sorry sorry not
black white to move black just played uh
bishop here to f7 attacking the queen so
my apologies white to move
uh and see if you can find an
improvement for what max lang did in the
game
there are a few really strong ideas but
i think only one of them is fully
winning in this position
and if you're watching this later feel
free to pause the video and come back
and check
okay hopefully you've had a little bit
of time
what max lang played in the game
was queen takes h6 check
and his idea is that once the king
recaptures this rook can move wherever
it wants to and activate the bishop
and max is going to try and win the game
in this way
interestingly enough
with the best play this is actually a
draw
the king can withdraw here back to g8
and it's going to be a weird wacky game
but black can hold on
however if you accept and take the queen
now white is winning
the best move in this position
is actually
rook takes f7 check
with the idea yeah may chess you got it
i knew what you were talking about um
yeah rick takes f7 with this idea that
okay well if you take with the queen
it's just over you're giving up your
queen so after knight takes uh a very
important idea
queen to g4 check
the king is completely locked so you
have to block and after you do bishop
takes and there's nothing that can be
done the queen is nearly trapped
you're either going to lose her or if
you try and save the queen
then something like bishop to f6
is gonna be more than enough to win uh
if the king goes to h6 queen g5 is
checkmate
and if the king goes to f7
then either bishop h4 or bishop d8 are
both checkmate
again the importance here is let's come
back
is instead of taking kind of a more
calculating approach and finding the
surefire victory maxline goes for this
uh really
sacrificial flashy line you know giving
up the queen and back in these days
again this game took place in 1868 there
was a little more maybe honor in
accepting a sacrifice if someone
sacrificed something you just have to
take it now we would want to calculate
and evaluate and say okay yeah king g8
is going to be a better move
but let's see how this game developed
so his opponent did take
and now rook g4 this is the best move
keeping the king locked
on the side of the board there's only
one move after the discovered check
king to h5 and now again
it's uh white to move
and again max lang opts for this very
flashy sacrificial idea
but he makes a mistake
so see if again take a second see if you
can find the best move in this position
for white
um
and we'll take a look in just a moment
again if you're watching at home
not live after this has been put up feel
free to pause the video and take a
second to figure it out
a lot to worry about in this position
for black's king
okay hopefully you've had enough time
but now let's take a look
the move max lang played in the game
that is a big mistake
is knight to g3 check
this is again a flashy sacrifice giving
up this rook
and there's an idea he has what happens
in the game is after king takes the only
move
rook to f5
and we're locking the king in
and it's going to be made soon
the improvement is actually to play rook
to f5 here
and we're keeping the king locked in
after the take now h3
king h4 and bishop to f2 checkmate
and it looks like okay well what's the
difference he stacks a rook in one key
sex work on another case but here's
where it matters
so after knight to g3
king takes rook to f5 there's a very
important difference
it's black to move
in this position i'll just tell you
max lang's opponent
just crumbled under this pressure it was
too much and he played the move h6
which allowed the same idea h3 king to
h4
and now the knight's in the way so
actually max length sacrifices another
piece beautifully
rook to h5 check there's only one move
and knight to f5 checkmate
max sacrifices almost all of his pieces
uh but still manages to get a beautiful
victory
however
he gave his opponent a chance
and here's how this connects to
everything
it's black to move
you've seen this continuation
we're about to play check
check checkmate
is there any way black can get out of
this
what would you play in this position
trying to survive
again take a second and look get some
ideas and i'll reconnect it to
everything we've been talking about so
far
okay hopefully you've had enough time
the crazy amazing move that max lang's
opponent should have played in this
position
is queen takes e4
sacrificing the queen
this is a crazy counter sacrifice that
probably his opponent wasn't even
considering but here's what happens is
after queen takes e4 it's really quite
simple
i mean what else are you going to do
you're going to take the queen
and now king takes f5 and the king is
out of the box
the bishop and knight aren't in a
position to force it over into this
corner and get a checkmate
and now black's just gonna start
activating their pieces
and how might you find a move like this
well
it's all about the material count
max lang has been sacrificing his pieces
this whole game like a lunatic and it
ends up working in his favor
spectacularly but if he had taken a
second and thought okay well rook f5 is
a good move but it's not check it's not
forcing
we give our opponent a move to play
and the reason we can sack a queen is
well let's look at the material right
now
uh
white has one two three four five six
pawns versus blacks one two three four
five okay lights up a pawn
but
white only has a knight bishop and rook
whereas black has a knight bishop and
rook
as well as two other bishops and a queen
so giving up the queen means that black
is still up a bishop and a rook
and that's not even counting the fact
that max is going to get this rook 2.
after queen takes e4
it's not defended the knight's going to
have to jump and take the queen
and now this is just
horrible we have a bishop and a knight
versus two rooks and a bishop
it's a hard move to see and it's not one
you might be consciously thinking about
but if you're in a game where maybe
you're winning a lot and
are you sorry you're losing in the
position your opponent is maybe a move
or two away from checkmate they give you
an opportunity keep an eye out uh
because if you are
you know this far ahead in material you
can make a move that sacrifices a queen
if it saves the game
it might
it might cost you but in this case it
would have worked really beautifully
so again the point of material count we
always got to keep this in the back of
our mind to help us evaluate yes max was
in a winning position because he could
have
played the best moves and found a
checkmate and that would have been great
but he missed it which gave us an
opportunity to take a look
and really evaluate okay well we have a
move it's not check
maybe we can get out of this
let's jump back to our other theme here
a piece activity
so when i say a piece is active i'm
talking about it being
centrally placed now in this case it's a
bit of a weird one but like a bishop or
a knight these pieces are very active
versus these pieces in the back row are
not because they're not in the game yet
so peace activity is really important in
evaluating the position
and this is one way that i can show a
good example is this is a
move a strategy that you may have
encountered if you're a more beginner
player and even if you're not you may
have encountered this at some point in
your chess career
where you're playing with the black
pieces or even with the white pieces
and your opponent plays
very very aggressively and they're just
going for like some kind of form of
checkmating idea
they're trying to
win all of your pieces get their queen
out and just make it really easy and
make you look silly
there are some important ways that we
can counter this type of strategy and it
revolves around peace activity
in this position for instance um without
explaining too in depth the theory maybe
we'll come back and look at how to deal
with opening queen attacks but right now
just the more basic ideas we're going to
develop our pieces play really solidly
we're bringing a knight out to defend
the center and defend our pawn which is
the immediate threat
if something like bishop to c4 obviously
threatening checkmate
a move like g6 pushing the queen away
between to f3
reigniting this threat and now again we
can get some pieces in the game
and all of this time white is spending a
lot of moves moving their queen back and
forth and out
um
and that's going to allow us to get a
little bit of an advantage because we
can start to get some of our pieces out
well they're just moving their queen
if they want to be really aggressive
it's going to cost them a lot
after a move like g4
if you don't know what to do this is
really scary if you just are like okay
well maybe i just developed my pieces
they can uh
cause a lot of damage so you do have to
be careful
but if you know the right continuation
let's take some more space
knight to d4 a really beautiful move
threatening the queen
threatening this beautiful fork
so now the queen has to really try and
defend everything we're attacking this
pawn
and all of these squares and look at how
much our pieces are controlling
the only really good move here is to go
to d1
you could try queen to the d3 but now
white's going to have even more trouble
with peace activity right this bishop is
going to have a harder time getting out
because this pawn can't move
regardless of what they play
either way
their pieces are hurting we now have
massive control here in the center
and what we're going to do now is try to
increase that a good move here to play
as d5 striking out in the center
and we don't actually care about this
pawn we're more interested in activating
our pieces getting our bishop in the
game
so say a move e takes d5 to keep the
bishop safe and now bishop takes g4
and this is looking really really bad
white has only one piece developed
versus r3
and now they're one it's actually even
behind a pawn it's even worse
all three of our pieces are aimed at
white
really they're king and their queen and
it's just very hard to stop um so maybe
a move played here could be f3 to try
and again prevent
taking the queen
and now a really really brutal move
knight to e4
with the point
that well you can't really take anything
if you take my knight
i get your queen
and if you take my bishop
then it's check me
so you don't really have any options
here um if you don't take anything i
mean i'm gonna do this anyway
the only way to really stop this is
probably to play h4 um
and yeah i don't even know
what
what white does here it's just too too
brutal
and we don't have to spend a lot of time
analyzing but i want to emphasize this
point that
a queen right materially is an extremely
powerful piece nine points
so much versatility
but if you aren't careful about how you
use that and you allow your opponent to
just readily develop their pieces
get some really nice control some good
piece activity your pieces are going to
be
worth way more they're going to be doing
more for you than your opponents
so that's another important thing to
consider when we're evaluating a
position
i would like to quickly go through a
really famous game
and this is uh morphe's opera house i'm
sure you've heard of it and i'm not
gonna again bog down in the analysis of
every move it's been done 100 million
times
but what i do want to emphasize is the
material count and why the decisions
morphe makes make a lot of sense even in
a materialist fashion
so the game starts if you're not
familiar with a philidor defense
that's indicated by this move d6 here
and white strikes in the center
all of these are theoretical moves
trading some pieces
and now white activates again peace
activity is crucial here the bishop and
the queen both pointing at this pawn
knight to f6
queen to b3 once again redirecting our
aim
queen to e7 and knight to c3 instead of
being a little material gravi instead of
just taking this pawn here
morphy decides you know i could win a
pawn but i would rather play really
solid and get my pieces in the center
give me lots of versatility
his piece activity is his priority here
c6 and bishop g5 and let's just take a
pause on this position
if we take a look
material is equal
we've traded a bishop for a knight
we've traded these two center pawns
everything else is the same
we have
seven pawns on each side we have a
bishop and a knight there's like two
bishops on a knight versus two knights
and a bishop a queen and two rooks it's
totally equal
but positionally this is terrible simple
game two yeah this is a terrible opening
by black there are ways to improve what
has been done uh but the way it is yeah
this bishop on f8
this knight here is now blocked by this
c6 pawn
the rooks are going to be impossible to
develop
all of this is uh
yeah very
very bad for black the pieces even
though they have the same amount they're
not active in any way
uh so black tries to make a bit of a
desperate play here trying to win a
little bit of time
and if you have seen this game you know
what's coming
uh knight takes b5 really brilliant idea
and we're sacrificing material
we're going to end up winning these two
pawns for this night so we're going to
be down a pawn
but morphy isn't concerned again with
this just simple material evaluation we
want to look a little bit deeper
after this exchange
white has sacrificed again a knight for
two pawns
but both of black's knights after this
move the only real move both of black's
knights are pinned
so the bishop is locking them down
either to the queen or the king meaning
they effectively can't move and aren't
controlling any space
okay so they're rendered useless
the bishop is stuck behind the queen
it's not going to get out anytime soon
uh and black's king side rook also
trapped in the corner behind the bishop
so really black only has one piece they
might be able to use and that's this
rook over here
but even still like if you compare that
to what white has going on both of these
beautiful active bishops the queen
there's a versatility in which way we
want to castle king side or queen side
activating our rooks even farther
and the whole point here
is
the peace activity ultimately is going
to trump just plain material again all
of this is context dependent
so let's see what happens next uh white
castles king side to improve the
pressure on this pin tonight on d7
rook to the eight defending and once
again we have a sacrifice
uh rook takes on d7 the material here is
less important
because morphe is recognizing yeah i
have
i'm giving up this rook
but if we really want to count material
pretty accurately we can just discount
these two pieces
these bishop and rook they're not in the
game at all it's tempting to almost even
discount the rook in the night here
because once again they're both pinned
so really the only piece black has
that's doing anything productive is this
queen
and it is trying desperately to hold
everything together it's trying to keep
the pawns the rook the night everything
safe the king ultimately and it's just
kind of failing
so understanding that morphe is
calculating material
and their value but he's evaluating not
just on the piece being on the board but
being in a position where it can do
something meaningful
this game ends in pretty spectacular
fashion
after queen to e6 morphe trades
and then finds a beautiful checkmating
idea
and we look and he sacrificed all of his
pieces save this bishop and rook
but unlike the max lang game none of
what morphe did was really flashy um
maybe except for this ending all of it
served a purpose
um
he was very aware of what his material
sacrifices were doing and how they would
lead him to this ultimate goal
uh rather than making some
little mistakes and allowing the
opponent the opportunity to breathe
okay
and we're going to move on here
to one more example that i want to look
at with you this is a really uh
fascinating game that i've done some
different looking and studying
and this game was between uh
renee martiner and bobby fisher
we'll start out uh bobby had the black
pieces by the way so we're gonna be
playing
as the opponent of bobby fischer hope
you're prepared for that
we have d4 knight to f6 c4 and g6 this
is indicating a king's indian style
defense
bishop to g7 and we're not going to
focus again too much on the opening here
now this this does look a little good
for um
white because now yeah you could argue
well look black's pieces are all pretty
silly here in the back i've got my
knight i've got my space this is
actually an okay opening for black
mostly because they're planning to
counter strike in the center
uh and
take advantage of maybe white's
overextending
but so don't worry too much about that
but again we get through this kind of
opening sequence and like i said black
is striking back in the center hoping to
get now some really nice piece
development
and we have some trades and exchanges
but let's get to
this position here
okay
so a lot's been traded
a lot has happened and we have some
complexity here
uh black's king is safe and castled
uh this knight is a little silly maybe
right now but it has some versatility in
terms of where it comes to develop
black has the option to
continue pushing forward with maybe f5
and e4 maybe continuing to threaten to
trade
and so and then also they have had this
queen on this nice line white pieces
look decent
maybe this queen is a little silly here
on b1 locking the rook in
but we have some nice knights and
bishops out in the center
we would want to definitely develop this
fishman castle but in this type of
position how would you
evaluate what's going on again some of
that would come through what i just said
materially we can take a look and i
believe
i don't think this is quite equal i
think it's close we might be up a pawn
three four five six one two three four
five six okay no pawns are equal
um so yeah it looks totally equal so
materially again we can say okay so
there's no
obvious immediate advantage
but now let's look at what the pieces
are doing once again we said
let's first go back to what i talked
about we're kind of in a middle game
here we're not quite in an end game yet
so the fact that these pieces are all
active is definitely a plus this knight
is maybe a little bit of a hindrance as
is this bishop
and we can also look at uh whether this
is an open or closed game
this is definitely maybe it's not fully
open we still have a pawn here on
e5 but it's much more open than closed
right we've exchanged at least three of
these center pawns
so
what does that tell us
the one that tells us maybe we should
value our bishops a little more
and if we actually look we can see that
yeah maybe bobby's knights aren't quite
as active as they could be
maybe not as active as ours but his
bishops are doing a lot of work
these pieces are really making some big
threats when this night moves there's
going to be an attack on our pawn here
with the bishop and the queen
when this pawn either pushes forward or
is traded the bishop is going to have
just a beautiful diagonal
and you compare that to our bishops well
this one's kind of blocked we don't
really have a great place for it we just
need to get it in the game to castle
and this bishop is okay eventually we
would love to trade it for this dark
square bishop here and infiltrate this
castle
but as it is right now it also doesn't
really have a lot of great places to go
so that's one thing we can look at we
can also talk about an open oh sorry we
just talked about open and closed game
something else that's important in the
open and closed game is to recognize
in a closed game you don't actually have
to castle as early
um
and if we actually i'm just going to
quickly jump back
but if we're in like a kind of closed
structure all these pawns are locked up
it's going to be actually pretty hard to
expose the king to an attack you don't
have to stress about it as much
versus in a more open game and i'll come
back to the game we're looking at right
now
this king is pretty exposed especially
once this pawn is traded
and both of these files open up for the
rooks for the queen
the bishops can come in
it's actually going to be really
dangerous for us really soon so that
could be a primary concern so we need to
get our king safe
for that reason
one of the uh not great moves in this
position is to take this pawn
as tempting as it looks right we just
lost the pawn we would love to just take
it back make it really simple not have
to worry about any discovered attacks
but the problem is
if we take this pawn whether it's with
our pawn
or with our knight maybe really
regardless of what takes there's going
to be an exchange
and no matter what happens
all of this is opened up and our king is
now extremely exposed
so again if we look at taking with the
pawn
i've drawn some arrows to try and help
illustrate but you can see this knight
is going to develop into the game and
the rooks are going to slide in and
attack the king
the bishop is now beautifully activated
on this diagonal the knight's hitting
everything the bishop and the queen are
working together
and this whole position is going to open
up really really fast and our king is
too exposed
the same thing happens if we take with
the knight it's going to be identical in
this case we have the queen and the
bishop working together to attack our
pawn here in the corner and maybe look
at the rook we have a pin we have to
worry about on our bishop that's not
defended
and again the king is too exposed
even if we play a move um that doesn't
trade maybe we play something like
knight to e4
um trying to control some valuable space
this doesn't look great because black
can now trade and we're going to have to
run away and even if we win that rook
i would
this is still much better for black
because again our king is too exposed
our knights have good center control but
it's too open
the bishops are going to dominate this
rook and queen are going to dominate
so all of that we have to consider even
if we're up material
so that's why in this game
uh martiner played the best move
he actually played f5 which does a few
things
one
it's lined up with our queen
so it's maybe trying to get our queen
which is on a bit of a silly square more
active
additionally we're preventing this pawn
from being easily traded now it can
still be pushed
but we'll worry about that when we come
to it um but we are making an immediate
threat
and now
bobby's turn to move and maybe we're
expecting him to
uh just take this pawn
we would not mind that at all right we
can trade the knight for the bishop
and now this pawn is still here
and there's some discovered threats i
would still say this is a little better
for black
but
because this pawn is in the way it's
going to be harder to attack our king so
we have a little more time to get our
bishop and our king castled
plus we've also weakened our opponent's
castle without this g-pawn it's going to
be a little easier for us to launch an
attack as well so it's a double-edged
sword
but instead of just taking this pawn and
again you can take it with the pawn or
bishop it wouldn't matter the position
is going to end up the same
bobby plays
a really interesting move maybe not the
best but it's going to make us think he
plays the move e4
and now we got a lot of questions to ask
it's a very complex position how do we
evaluate it
let's survey this scene
our knight is attacked their bishop is
attacked so we have an instant option
maybe we can trade some pieces
do we want to trade pieces well let's
take a look say we take this bishop
what's going to happen
i think this is going to be a little
problematic
this is actually what happens in the
game after they take our
knight
g takes f3
and again just look at our pieces
our rook our queen our bishop and our
kingside brook
all are just sitting here on the back
rank our king is totally exposed
um as soon as this pawn is dealt with
and black can open up with the rooks
this is going to be really really hard
to survive this is what was played in
the game
maybe better
would have been to consider
a move like knight take c4 so now
instead of taking this pawn maybe we're
taking here i don't like this as much
because now we have to deal with this
potential pin
maybe this is a little better than well
this is certainly better than if we had
taken the pawn
uh but this is still maybe not the quite
the best move because we are again now
having to worry about an attack on our
king
finally uh let's take a second here and
see if anyone can figure out the best
move so we've looked at taking this pawn
with the knight and we've looked at
taking this bishop
with our pawn
and in both cases it's a little
lackluster i still think black is better
but there is a move that actually gives
us some fighting chances here
and it might be a little hard to see
but the move that's actually really
really good
is queen takes e4
and the reason is even though we're
maybe giving up this pawn one day and
maybe we're giving up this one
it's all about activity our queen is now
much more active here in the center and
is going to be able to play a vital role
in both
offense and defense
maybe she'll be able to buy us a little
time to get castled
maybe even queen side if we really have
to if it's that desperate
but we're going to need to get our king
out of harm's way soon
and we can look at a possible
continuation right their bishop is still
under attack so maybe
pawn takes f5
if they just stick with the bishop then
we're happy to trade right a knight is
going to be worse than a bishop in this
really open game where there's all this
space and our queen is going to have
some nice impact on the king side
uh and if the pawn takes
i would recommend we not take back
uh but instead we
just get our queen to a nice square
maybe we attack their queen
i would be happy to make a trade like
this when the board is so open my king
is very exposed
you can also maybe consider going to h4
to keep up some activity and some
pressure
but if we were in this position to take
the pawn with our knight this could lead
us into some trouble not because of
bishop takes that would transpose to the
nice variation because of knight to f6
and now they're activating their pieces
again
they're knights out of the way the rooks
so the rooks are going to slide over the
knight's attacking the queen
and their queen is still ready and able
to come in a lot of things we got to
worry about one possible continuation
could be
queen to c2
bishop takes queen takes
rook f to e8
and now how do we deal with all of these
threats our bishop is pinned and queen
to uh
a5 is a potential threat we have to
worry about one day not immediately
because our queen is covering it but we
have to be aware of it
so king to f2 i mean we need to keep our
bishop in the game
and now there's a really devastating
move rook takes e3 king takes
and bobby would be very happy to
sacrifice material because he's
activating his pieces
especially because our king is right
here out in the open um it is very
compelling to give up a rook for a
bishop down that exchange in order to
launch this massive attack
running away isn't really going to do us
any good
um because black's resources are too
strong
you can see there's checkmating threats
already
and we don't have to continue much
farther in this line
but those are the things we need to be
worried about when we're evaluating this
position
and you don't have to think in terms of
that whole line but just think in that
general trend
what is our biggest problem in this
position we don't want the
position to open up so if we trade
it's going to open up they're rooks
they're bishops their knight their queen
all of these pieces are going to come
alive and attack our king who is just
sitting here
lowly in the center
unfortunately that's what did happen in
the game f takes e6
pawn takes f3 g takes and again just
look at these pieces how poorly
developed they are
even though we are winning in material
we are losing because
just their pieces are doing a lot more
they're doing more work
in this position bobby plays the move f5
with the threat here of moving forward
and forking our knight in our bishop so
we need to do something about that uh f4
was the move played in the game seems
reasonable
and now knight to f6
and bobby fischer is really striking at
all of our weaknesses this bishop is now
just doing very little
the knight's going to come in and cause
a big problem control some really
important squares and do it relatively
uncontested so bishop e2
preparing the castle but more
importantly covering the square so the
knight can't easily jump in and provoke
us
and now rook f to e8
and you can already see we're not going
to be able to defend this pawn
and
this line is too important it is okay
for bobby to be down a little bit of
material
because his activity is much better
king to f2 um
you could try castling here might be a
little better but regardless it's not
going to be enough
rook takes c6
rook to e1 rook 8 to e8
doubling with a threat to take
bishop to f3
and now in this position it is
black to move
i will actually flip the board here
because
no longer do we have to try and stress
about fighting bobby fischer well we've
moved past that point now it's our turn
to think with bobby fischer and see if
we can figure out a way to win
evaluating this position
what might we look at what might come to
our minds to try and take advantage here
again we're thinking about material
uh and again i think we might be
actually no material looks even it's
just a bishop versus a knight so that's
okay but if you look at our activity
that's the important part is our knights
are controlling the center very well
making a lot of threatening squares
the queen's on a decent square um the
bishop's controlling a little bit of
space so it's going to be hard to
infiltrate immediately but we have some
nice diagonals to work with here
our bishop as soon as this knight moves
is going to open up an attack in the
corner and obviously our doubled rooks
is a major
advantage putting a lot of pressure here
on the e-file
so trying to find the best move
again take a little bit of time but
don't stress if you can't find it it's a
bit of a harder one
um
yeah i don't know how to pronounce your
name
kuribo something but that king is not in
a great space i agree
uh and we're actually going to see why
in this position uh black to move and we
have a really beautiful sacrifice
rook takes e3
and we're down in exchange rook for a
bishop
brook takes e3 rook takes e3 king takes
c3
and bobby has gotten the king out in the
center
so we've definitely achieved
that but now how do we finish this
attack
there's a really beautiful tactical
strike so if you have any ideas
go ahead and take a look see if you can
find what's the tactical strike here
how can we finish this game in a really
beautiful fashion
we're down some material but this queen
and this rook are virtually out of the
game so we don't have to worry about
them if we can find a way to end it here
any ideas from the chat or our live
audience
how can we finish this game as black
what
oh that's okay
okay i have a few people who in the chat
j robert
gr
and fertiset who both have the idea
queen takes f4
really just stunning sacrifice um the
purpose here isn't to try and find all
the best tactics but to think about what
we've achieved
uh if we look at this the king can run
away certainly um anywhere he goes
that's not defending a piece we're just
going to win this bishop
but even if he goes back here i mean i
guess
we're just fine um
something like this maybe just checked
and
that looks pretty good
so the obvious move is going to be to
take
and the problem here
does anyone see it
yeah karubo you saw it too
uh yeah
bishop to h6
checkmates controlling all of the key
squares and the king is just fully
trapped
so what is the purpose of that let's go
back
to the very beginning here
and the purpose of all of this
is to think how do we evaluate these
positions
maybe you do some memorizing of opening
theory and that's great um but that's
only going to take you so far until you
understand why the moves you're playing
are what you're playing
what their purposes is what their point
is it's hard to
move forward
if we look at this position already
already black has an advantage um the
bishops are beautifully lined up uh this
night while it's sitting here on the
back it's still in a versatile square
once these pawns are exchanged it's
probably going to jump back to f6 maybe
after f5 is pushed and we also have the
option to jump in either of these
squares at some point as well
um
and if you compare that to white's
pieces
they have these two pieces which aren't
really doing much the knight's
controlling a few nice squares maybe um
but this would much this knight would be
much better if there were maybe a
kingside attack going on which just
isn't really happening and doesn't have
the potential at least right now because
we gotta worry about our king first
uh and so again if you just look at how
to evaluate the position it starts with
material you have to start there
um so your name for this opening this is
a king's indian
i don't know what this this e5 there is
a line here i think it's a sideline
i think the main move in this position
is probably just knight f3
there's different ways to play um
but uh to get back to my closing point
is if we think about all this the way
you evaluate a position you have to
start at the very basics how many pieces
do i have how many does my opponent have
and then you move to why are those
pieces valued the way they are
if we go to again one of our positions
like this closed game
this night
it's controlling a lot of important
central squares
and there's really nothing that can
challenge it
so we have to take those things into
consideration
one what pieces do we have and two how
are they being used if you're trying to
make a plan you want to look at the
pieces you have and think okay what's a
move i could play that would improve
some of my pieces or maybe what pieces
is my opponent using that are really
strong can i trade them off for
something that i'm not using
this is a good way to start to think
about
improving your chess
so i really hope that this was valuable
for you again it was a pretty basic
intro to
to the beginner breakdown series but by
surveying the scene by evaluating these
positions
by counting our material and then really
thinking about what it's worth and how
we can improve it uh you're gonna be on
a really good way to start improving
your chess
again my name's alex it's been a
pleasure
and i hope to see you again next week
[Music]
you